hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to I and bread now I
took a little breather I meditated I
didn't really but I felt I thought about
peaceful thoughts and I just want to get
this done now so that I can bury it for
the rest of my days and I don't know if
I'm going to be able to do that but
hopefully everything will be fine let's
do this I'm okay with this
this seems okay I think I can
emotionally handle this one because this
one at least this one is something not
horrified let's all pretend like that
didn't happen it was just that whisper
on the wind
nothing happened bad and we're all
a-okay got it cool all right here we go
alright let's take a 200 ha-hee joy joy
joy inside my soul so it's all inside my
heart heart heart I'm feeling good
Jordan no not in my house no no no and
now we fly and now we don't die
remember that don't die okay
oh god you flap slow oh it's not correct
but I'm going to take it oh okay we're
fine oh we're not fine we're not fine
we're not like oh hi happy happy joy joy
happy happy joy joy oh happy happy joy
joy oh my god if you could just you know
not do those things that you're doing
now that'd be great
Oh pom pom pom me ah okay the flip was a
nice touch I suppose okay which gotta
ignore the bird pube will be okay oh ho
ho
under the wipers Oh Oh interesting
strategy oh thank you I am stuck oh joy
there we go oh you're so cute oh I don't
know what you're doing I don't know
anymore you can do this if I just
believe in myself if I believe in the
heart of the brand okay ah okay you
didn't grab on there I think see where
you went wrong okay you're just humping
bricks now that's that's not that's not
that's not what I okay if I let go are
you gonna fall over you are good you are
oh my god Oh
oh I didn't think you were and you
betrayed me and that's the thanks I owe
I went the long way around didn't I I
could have gone that way and I would
have been just fine wouldn't I have ha
okay that is not ideal
how do I go oh oh whoa okay we got it
okay just slap something slap something
stop okay that's an option okay
what are you doing you're so energetic
and I don't like it
slap why did I bother going the long way
around I have no idea I have no I have
no idea
okay camera I don't like you very much
and you don't like me but oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh oh my oh my god oh my god go
wow wow what is it do I need that I
don't know what that is but okay oh okay
get stuck I guess okay hold I don't know
what we did oh yeah oh oh
just rest rest just rest take a break I
don't know what we did oh we did
something up there you were you were you
were up there you were up there what
broke
what's sparking oh my god you are
kidding me do I go under it or do I go
over it I don't know I don't know what I
need to do is glass there I don't think
anybody even notices what I think is
weird anymore but you know what it's
fine
think I can make it over if I sprint
across the ground here no faster oh oh
not that way oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god no no not like this oh why
why would you do that to me why would
you do that to me why would you do that
to me why would you do that to me oh
yeah oh oh oh
slay can you just grab on what why I
don't understand your logic flailing in
the wind oh god oh god oh god oh my god
oh my god just all [ __ ] you're gonna run
out of grip aren't you right out of grip
right well why are you slapping her so
bad oh no just go oh
lighters I like the sound of that whoa
whoo clickety clickety Flula
Oh Sparky okay so what about that
I get it oh I get it it's not that the
sparks why okay holy [ __ ] oh my god Oh
Tom the [ __ ] down okay all right nail
this so it's not that the sparks are
what's gonna give it to me
it is the gas that I spilled and that oh
why why why did you do that why you
explain yourself to me please why why
did you do that
why did you just do that how did you
just do that what in the [ __ ] okay there
we go
ah not where I want a kit there we go
okay now that that's sparking if I pour
gas there it'll light on fire right
right and fire is what I want right
right to burn every copy of this game in
existence that's what I want
Oh Frick it go why why are you oh oh no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
don't panic don't panic oh my god why
are you not going oh my god
oh my god are you kidding me No oh my
god what the [ __ ] there we go oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh oh yeah Chaos Rings oh
yeah
chaos reigns and that means that I
can roast myself if I can just get that
power up oh oh oh what what I get what
are you doing get oh my god oh my god no
oh [ __ ] god oh my god I'm okay so
long as I think happy thoughts I'll be
just fine because I am almost there with
barely any edibility left oh no no no
not like this
no you piece of [ __ ] I was just calm I'm
fine okay it's a raging fire yes raging
fire yes okay
[Music]
what oh-oh-oh
hey I gotta be okay okay I did it and I
don't know what that epilogue is but I
I'll look at it I'm gonna look at it and
then if it's something
why to whom it may concern' it was the
bread it's always been the bread needed
to become toast and he will not stop at
nothing my house was to start but it
won't be the end I was forced to escape
in therapy barn I should have destroyed
the bread while I had the chance
now there's been an explosion across
town and I know it's the bread I'm gonna
find that cursed loaf and end this once
and for all
I don't want it I I don't I don't I
don't want to do this
no oh no way oh no not happening
nope not gonna do that not now not not
my mouth not now
that is all for I am bread for I cannot
handle emotionally another level of that
I've done three in a row and that was
pushing my sanity but I feel good now
because I do it I did everybody I did it
or ever be I did it so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
everyone who believed in me all this
time
and I will get to the epilogue as soon
as I'm mentally recovered from this
exhausting
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]